hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday is dev stream
recap day like always sorry this video
is going to be a little bit later than
usual usually these videos get uploaded
by 2 or 3 p.m.
around my time but it is about 6 p.m.
when I'm recording this it is because
the whole stream was a combination of
season 5 info with some tournament
matches as well so I had to weave
through all the [ __ ] matches just to
get to the info so that's why and the
stream is still going on but all the
info is displayed so now I'm about to
make this video so let's get started so
to start we have a lot to talk about
with the character reworks of conquer
berserker and Ken's site and I have some
videos of explanation
so arena mode stuff to talk about and a
few other bits of details
so first up dedicated servers will be
coming at February 19th on PC with
consoles following soon after that which
is probably going to be a week after so
it's very exciting if none of you do
know that the season 5 is coming out on
the 15th in February so about four days
after dedicated servers will be out on
PC like I said the council following
probably a week after next up is
probably the biggest thing of this whole
video and it is the character reworks
Ken se is followed up with them by
conker and then Berserker I will leave
the full patch notes in the description
if you want to follow along or read for
yourself also most of the names on these
were named by the movesets so I don't
exactly know since I don't play every
character so if I can't fully explain
what the what the combo is in particular
they're talking about I apologize for
that
so let's get started with Ken's a so one
decently big change is now his top heavy
finisher has a different animation and
can now be canceled into a guard break
it cannot cancel it to dodge now only
happens at the same time as the side
cancels in faint timings but for his top
three heavies in the chain these side
cancels for the first top heavy it the
top heavy cannot be canceled into the
first side attack dodge and new melee
move pummel strike which we'll get to
and if you're doing the second top heavy
in the chain it can now be cancelled in
two side attacks which is light and
heavy dodge and guard break for the
timing changes his top his first top
heavy strike is now gonna be 1000
milliseconds and same with his second
top heavy they were originally 700
milliseconds so basically they're gonna
be a little bit slower but for the
damage his first side light and the
chain is now going to do 12 damage
instead of 20 second side lights going
to do 16 instead of 20 damage and the
third side light is going to do 2
instead of 25 damage but that seems like
a little bit of a nerf because obviously
can't say his lights are pretty fast
that new now less damage but his heavy
attacks now do 40 damage as opposed to
30 damage now for both the top heavy the
first and the second one so basically to
summarize that his heavies are going to
be a lot slower and do a lot more damage
with the light attacks being the normal
same but doing just a tad bit more
damage making Kent's A's use the heavy
attacks more and we'll get into why
that's a very key thing in a moment so
next up is the new move that he has
called pummel strike I met you may have
seen it in the clip that I'm showing in
the background of Ken's a that I took
from the stream but basically in the
first top-heavy in the chain it can now
be canceled into an unblockable pummel
strike I believe you can use that by
just pressing the guard break button he
will basically take the bottom of his
huge-ass sword but he takes the thing
and just bashes him in the head with it
to do some stun damage as well and to do
some stamina damage it's basically to
break Turtles a lot of people will
turtle up against Ken's day and he can't
really do much this is supposed to break
them so now he has a solution
next up Ken says new chains are gonna be
a little bit reworked he now has four
different chains the heavy light light
heavy light heavy heavy heavy light and
light heavy light as well swift strike
and home splitter are getting a little
bit of a rework swift strike if you
don't remember is decide that a side
dash into hourly side national light
attack where he'll basically kind of do
like a weird 90 degree turn and then hit
you with his blade kind of like a weird
spin move but it now causes the heavy
hit and block reaction it is now formed
using the heavy input button now instead
of it being a light attack button and is
now considered a heavy attack allows
executions cost six more stamina than
normal so now it's 12 instead of six and
also suffers the heavy parry penalty now
the parry penalty meaning if you if your
heavy attack is parried they get a free
light if your light attack is parried
they get a free heavy we talked about
that in last week's video so definitely
want to check that out if you missed
that the helm splitter is now going to
be considered a light attack again and
is interrupted when blocked meaning
before when he did the helm splitter he
can move into a top heavy irony and any
of those type of moves regardless if it
was blocked now is if you're blocked
with this move you immediately set back
to neutral and the damage has now been
reduced to 17 it used to be 20 Ken's I
also was getting a second new move
called nature's wrath it is performed by
doing a dodge forward into a heavy so it
is similar to the helm splitter except
instead of doing the light attack you're
going to be pressing the heavy attack
button it is going to be visualized as
an overhead strike using the old
top-heavy finisher from before this
patch the original one
the attack is blockable the strike is
800 milliseconds and does 20 damage and
it has super huge forward movement the
only way that this is actually useful to
me that I've seen is it's to basically
catch people that roll away usually when
people do attacks or they're low on
health or something like that those do
instead of just dashing away they'll
actually roll away this this move will
actually catch them and obviously they
will take damage from it so that is to
help Ken se out especially in group
fights when this happens next up this is
dodging as you guys know Ken say it has
superior block on his dodges if you
forward dodge with the superior block
phase now starts a hundred milliseconds
to the end of the dodge and you will end
up in the top stance same thing for the
right and left so basically to summarize
that if any direction you dodge your
guard stance is going to be in that
direction once you finish that dodge
just so you know just ahead of time if
that seems a little bit weird that is
the change can't say got a little bit of
a rework on his own attack as well the
zone attack has been reworked into a
three strike attack the first strike is
500 milliseconds from the left guard
stance hitting your lock target and that
flows into a similar version of the old
zone attack for the second and third
strike it is no longer has
uninterruptible stance and all strikes
now have increased knocked back
especially when in revenge basically
what you I would assume you want to do
is do what you would normally do it no
Busha or PK you would want to do the
first hit in the zone and then kind of
cancel it because according to this the
second and the third hit are more
similar to the ones from his actual zone
attack and as we know those are very
like really slow really shitty moves so
you probably want to do the first hit in
the zone and then cancel it and probably
want to do that if you're going to do
Kent's a zone attack next up is conquer
and for conquer his charged heavies are
now unblockable there is no type of
scenario where you have to go uncharged
level one charged and fully charged it
is just either fully charged or a normal
heavy attack a pink flash will show when
it is fully charged and the charged
finished earthing has been removed the
fully charged attack takes 900
milliseconds to do top heavy unblockable
800 milliseconds and does 44 damage with
the side heavy unblockable doing 700
milliseconds with 700 milliseconds and 3
or 33 damage as well conquer can no
longer launch a light attack while
charging and the chance in the stands
changed while charging is now 100
milliseconds as the post - 300 so it's a
little bit faster basically to summarize
the full charge is going to take 900
milliseconds it is a quicker attack from
the side but also does less damage as
opposed to the top which is longer but
does more damage the superior block
probably one of the most controversial
things conker has once again is going to
be getting removed he no longer has the
superior block like he used to
superior block is going to be on heavy
openers fully charged heavy openers
front and side dodges and now full block
stance which we'll get into in a bit he
is also going to be getting a new move
called shield uppercut all heavies can
be canceled into the new move shield
uppercut it is a eight hundred
millisecond attack unblockable melee
does 10 stamina damage has immunity of
guard breaks at the start at the 100
milliseconds into the strike and the
shield uppercut will actually do damage
if you have the shield bash or feet on
basically the whole reason for this is
if you do a heavy attack and the person
dodges it let's say it's an assassin
they just dodged to the side you cancel
that into the shield uppercut do some
stamina damage maybe knock them into a
wall or something like that and kind of
trip them up a bit
conkers chain attacks have also been
reworked his light attack now can follow
into any light heavy or shield bash
mix-up heavy attack and I'll be
following into any light heavy or shield
bash mix-up and the shield bash can now
be followed into any light or heavy he I
kind of see this as the arm Musha or
berserker infinite chain type of attack
but now with instead of just having
lights and heavies he can outdo the
shield bash adding four more moves more
trickery a lot of good stuff on conquer
for this one as well his light attacks
are going to be doing 15 damage instead
of 12 and they're going to be 100
milliseconds faster regardless if it's
the opener or if it's and the infinite
strikes which is a good thing for him
and for the full block stands conquer
can zone attack from full block stance
but he can no longer shield bash for
post dodge or any basic attack during
full block stance or full block stance
exit and when like I said successfully
blocking an attack in full block stance
full block stance defense is not
considered superior as opposed to before
which was regular full block stands
entry is now 100 milliseconds slower but
his full stance exit is going to be 200
milliseconds faster so it's gonna be a
little bit slower on the entry but a
little bit faster trying to get out of
it because you obviously wanted to do
the zone attack or any of those moves if
the opponent happens to whiff an attack
right in front of you the stamina cost
for entering full block stance is now 20
it used to be 6 so it's gonna be a
little bit more and the regen is
immediately after full block stance has
been removed there used to be a
cool-down on 4 seconds before you would
start regen examina from it that is not
the case as soon as you exit full block
stance now it's actually a lot quicker
like I said you will immediately start
regaining your stamina back and then he
also has a new move which is called the
flail uppercut which is going to be
replacing the shield bash for pasta but
the flail uppercut is going to be the
shield bachelor past replacement and now
like I said it replaces it and the
strike is 500 milliseconds the shield
Bachelor policies to be 800 so now it's
similar to a light attack as opposed to
a heavy the flow uppercut uses the heavy
input does 30 damage and can execute so
if any of you concur players are out
there as soon as you do a full block
stance and you block an attack you can
go immediately into flail uppercut and
then that will give you 30 damage and
can execute and it is a heavy attack
input next up is the shield bash mix-up
after I hit branching into a light
attack is now 400 milliseconds was at 0
so it's going to be a little bit slower
to get into a light after a hit
branching into a heavy F and full block
stance is also going to be 400
milliseconds it was 300 so just a little
bit slower
the shield bash mix-up is slightly
better at tracking opponents who always
dodge sideways and it now does 10
stamina damage instead of 20 and then
the last three things we need to talk
about is the charging shield crushed the
top heavy and the zone attack so to
start the top heavy now does 33 damage
and instead of 25 his charging shield
crush which is the move where he
Sprint's out of stamina and just runs at
you shoves the shield right in your face
and knocks you flat on your ass the hit
recovery is now 300 milliseconds longer
no longer forces conquer into out of
lock the hit area is reduced
horizontally and the shield and the
charging shield across now those 10
stamina damage instead of 0 but knocks
the opponent about 0.5 meters backwards
according to the devs you used to get
some guarantee damage off of this this
is now enabling people
to get up before any attack is used
because conquerors would 100% rely on
this during duels they would just run
away and then she'll bash you if they
were able to hit you and get that
guarantee damn it's kind of like a big
cheese but now this is mostly used for
group fights when the opponent isn't
looking so that is definitely good on
them and then for the zone attack
conquer can now be parried properly on
the second hit or later it is no longer
interrupted by blocking a minion strike
and when activated from full block
stance we removed a 100 millisecond gap
on startup where Conqueror had no
defense so now if you're hit within that
100 millisecond gap going from full
block stance the zone attack you will
you will not be hit out of the move and
then finally we have Berserker his
videos getting incredibly long I do
apologize but this is a lot of info to
take in moving on with Berserker his
light and heavy openers light opener and
heavy opener now gain uninterruptible
stance if used immediately in a feint
the side lay openers are now 400
milliseconds if used immediately after a
feint and the top light opener is going
to be 500 milliseconds if used
immediately after a feint the light
openers damage has also been reduced off
to 15 as opposed to what it used to be
which was 17 the heavy finisher his
heavy finishers his third side heavy
finisher is now unblockable and now does
45 damage instead of 30 and his second
top heavy finisher is now unblockable
and those 30 instead of 55 the dance of
the parried blades which is the infinite
combo attack I like to call it the
infinite light attacks from the second
strike onward now do 400 millisecond
attacks instead of 500 so they're going
to be a little bit faster the infinite
light attacks from the second strike
onward now do 15 damage instead of 12
and the heavy attacks from the second
strike onward now do 25 instead of 20 so
summarize that the dance of the parried
blades the lights are going to be doing
a little bit more damage heavies are
gonna also be doing a little bit more
damage and the light attacks from that
strike are not going to be a little bit
quicker you're gonna have to get our
reaction time a little bit higher next
up is the bear mauler and that is the
triple heavy attack that no one really
uses as Berserker because of how easy it
is to parry the second heavy attack now
does 35 instead of 20 damage it's a
pretty obvious one because of how slow
the move said it was how slow the move
is being three heavies in a row they're
going to make it do a little bit more
damage and head slicer is
going to now has uninterruptible stands
at a hundred milliseconds and it was 300
a next big change is deflect and now
that now the player requires to press
the guard brake button when doing a
deflect as before you didn't have to
this was mostly because beserker players
would obviously get stuck in the
animation now I play gladiator and he
obviously has a deflect too if I were to
do a deflect I would just deflect the
person and if I didn't do the right move
I would just do the deflect and that's
it but Berserker would be locked in the
animation of course
so that is to keep everyone on the same
level so yes you're going to have to
learn to press the X button or whatever
the thing happens to be for your
preferred platform for the zone attack
Berserker moves about one meter further
forward than usual
so that's a good thing his slashing rush
which is the same exact thing as his own
attack but doing it backwards now cost
65 stamina instead of 12 can no longer
execute no longer has extra stamina cost
if you missed the attacker parried and
if it's parried it uses the shorter
heavy parried reaction which like we
said heavy gets parried freelite like
it's parried free heavy one thing is the
throws the forward thrill for Berserker
now does zero damage because before when
he threw you forward he would hit you in
the stomach with his axe and that would
do about eight damage that now it's not
the case it does zero damage same to the
side and back throws as well but they
all now do 20 stamina damage instead of
40 so it's gonna be a little bit less
for the throws a little bit of a nerf to
that but it's going to be good for
everybody else because that seemed to be
a little bit unbalanced on that and
according to the devs and that is it for
the character rout perks like I said
there is a [ __ ] load in this video and
this video is going way longer than it
needs to be hopefully this would be a
little bit shorter when I do the editing
but either way Highlander and Nobu she
also got some but I talked about that
and the majority of my last video so
click on the I in the top right or to be
taken to that or it'll be the end of
this video if you want to check that out
definitely especially if you're a
Highlander no bushi player let me get
let me know what you guys think about
these reworks I think they're okay I
especially love the Kent's I want I
can't wait to hop back in to Kent State
and actually use him and feel a little
bit more stronger now but like I said
this full patch notes in the description
as well patch 1.19 if you do want if you
did want to read those with me or read
by yourself follow along that's also in
the description as well and then lastly
we have the arena training mode that
comes with the apprentice and warriors
else to better your skills the devs have
changed the original training mode to
have a little bit of a cinematic look
which looks nice by the way have to
admit and a point system to notify you
if you're doing the move right or not if
you get enough points you rank up and I
assume you get to unlock more trials and
tutorials that way but there's also some
side objectives at the top right if you
complete them you also get extra points
to rank up I believe in the clip one of
them was to counter G be someone off a
Ledge or guard break off a ledge if you
complete that you'll get some extra
points and once again move up in the
rank for the actual arena they have
three different arenas with each
factions of each faction gets their own
distinct one you could toggle options in
the arena like health settings revenge
and damage settings for your opponent
like telling them will move you want
them to use I believe in the example the
person used a peacekeeper and used only
one move so that they can get the timing
down for that move as well you can also
see how much damage each individual
attack does to see if one hit is more
beneficial than the other you can also
put specific moves at the top and of the
top right of your screen so you can
memorize the move that way instead of
having to look back in the meta and the
move set menu every single time you
forget and you can also swap different
heroes on the fly and choose different
presets like in this example this the
dev switch from a PK to a warden and
chose and had the option of choosing
between a warden that only does more
taxes or a warden that only does the
shoulder bash once to help you fight
those different playstyles of characters
that you will come across in for honor
and then finally the best thing is that
daubeny is the leader of the Nights
arena I'm not sure about the Vikings or
the samurai the dev said that there was
a few people in there that we may have
missed
but daubeny is the leader of the Knights
one so it's automatically the best arena
and that's just beautiful we finally
found out where he went also while I end
the video I know that the executions
came out it is a three minute video and
I do not want to play this entire thing
because this video is way longer than it
needs to be and I really hate long
videos because those tend to get super
boring after a while I will leave it in
the description with all the other [ __ ]
I just mentioned as well if you want to
check out the thing for your character
but I'm also going to be putting it in
the background as well but I have a
feeling I won't be able to reach the
three-minute time limit of this whole
video so if I do happen to miss one of
your characters click in the description
watch the execution video and we'll be
all set and with that guys I hope and
like I said that is going to be the end
the video like the video if you guys did
enjoy I do appreciate the support on
last week's video it is not my most
popular video on this channel super
appreciate the views and all the support
you guys can give me and the tons of
subs we passed 5k it recently did make a
video on that appreciate you guys a lot
if you're new here subscribe we cover
the news the leaks the updates and the
patch notes a for honor I get that
informational side all on here for all
of you guys to see my two most recent
videos are going to be on screen where
we talked about the XP boost faction
more updates rep 50 new weapons refined
gear and the Highlander and no bushi
rivers and tons more if you want to know
all the info on season 5 definitely
check out these last two videos you'll
get caught up and up to speed with
everybody else in the community with
that guys I hope you have a great rest
of your day thank you all for the love
and support on the past videos and
hopefully this one as well but anyway
who have a great rest your day and peace
out